next up another fun surprise for you  guys the outlast trials in this horror  survival game you play a part of the  murkoff corporation you're a test  subject in a controlled training  facility in the middle of the cold war  era red barrels up in my home country of  canada has been hard at work on this  game where you can face the trials solo  or with up to three others in  multiplayer and tonight i am so honored  to world premiere the brand new trailer  for this game launching in 2022  [Music]  i want you to know that you are safe  i'm your friend  why did you come here  [Music]  but  your behavior  don't fight the process  thank you for volunteering for the  therapy  we are all  going to get better  together  you